what do you want to do when you grow
when you grow up
um i want to
be a doctor of course and
also
become a medical researcher and also be
the president of the united states
oh
[Applause]
good for wow
you know tanisha i don't know if you've
noticed but it's not a requirement that
the president be that smart
we've had smart ones we've also had
really dumb ones so
you'd be a very smart president that
would be impressive uh i'm curious
what's your idea of fun you're 11 years
old what do you like to do
okay
we could really
people that work here are not as smart
as you
someone just committed suicide there's
an 11 year old guy backstage just
realized that an 11 year old he's
smarter than he's a hundred times
smarter than him just jump just kick the
chair out
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what the hell is wrong with you trust me
tanishq
but you're 11 years old what's your idea
of fun what do you do for fun i have a
lot of things that i like to do for fun
i do like to play around and i also i
like to play around with my sister and i
have some
friends you know friends that are my own
age
and um
i i also like to learn that's something
i like to do a lot i well learning is
fun yeah what kind of things you like to
learn for fun well right now i wanna i'm
trying to learn quantum mechanics
you're trying to learn quantum mechanics
for fun
okay you're learning how are you doing
this are you online are you reading
books what are you doing to learn
quantum mechanics i'm reading i have i
got this book um last um this christmas
um
um
so i got this you got a quantum
mechanics book for christmas it was on
my christmas list it was on your
christmas list
seriously was it on the top of your
christmas list what was on your
christmas list now i'm curious okay
well i did really want some biological
equipment and some enzymes
you wanted enzymes for christmas
santa was so happy
i can finally unload this quantum
mechanics textbook
uh don't mind them
those guys are dumb
not like you and me denise um so
so you got did you get the enzymes
no
i guess you were pretty bad this year
but yeah i did i really wanted also this
amazing calculator too and of course the
quantum mechanics book and i got that
goes without saying yeah but the amazing
calculator what's so great about this
calculator it's a ti 84 one of the
coolest graphing calculators there is
one of the coolest yeah the ti-84 that's
like the best that's like the best there
are better ones too but that's extremely
cool it's got like apps on them you know
you can upload pictures you can like
you can like create equations for
a set of points it can do integrals
derivatives you can do linear algebra
not a not a typical calculator i'm like
a cat watching a ping pong
[Laughter]
you just look into my eyes and you see
nothing there
um you uh you're interested in string
theory as well i hear a lot about string
theory but i i don't understand it do
you think you understand string theory
i understand the basics but when i learn
quantum mechanics that will probably be
the next thing i'll learn wow along with
the theories of relativity okay